people sometimes ask what does it all
mean and that's a very hard question to
address because it's not clear what an
answer would look like a question that I
found much more fruitful that I think
one can address sensibly is does the
world embody beautiful ideas that's a
question we can address on both sides
what is the world and what is beauty
what is the world of course is the kind
of question that science addresses what
is beauty is something that art and
philosophy and human culture addresses
and so we can look at the record of what
people have found beautiful what they
were hoping for in their understanding
of the world with what the remarkable
understanding of the world we've
achieved in recent years looks like and
we can therefore frame a meaningful
discussion and a meaningful question a
meaningful meditation on the issue of
does the world embody beautiful ideas
some of the things that people at the
beginning of this adventure we're hoping
for and had in their visions was in
Pythagoras the idea that the world
embodies harmonies that he talked about
a music of the spheres Plato had a
theory of atoms based on the so called
botanic solids which are very symmetric
objects they were hoping that our sense
of Harmony so somehow agreed with what
nature likes to use and her construction
of the world and more specifically with
with Plato and the platonic solids the
idea that ideas that symmetry and
mathematical perfection provide the
building principles that the world
embodies those themes which Pythagoras
and Plato articulated very well
in the early days have inspired people
for centuries prior to the modern times
when we found that nature does in fact
use those ideas visual imagery is very
important to our understanding of the
world because humans are intensely
visual creatures depending on how you do
the accounting between twenty and fifty
percent of our brain is devoted to
processing visual information and we
have some very impressive capabilities
in that direction we face in
interpreting the world a very
challenging problem that we're good at
solving we're so good at it with that we
don't consciously realize how difficult
it is that's the problem of taking the
electromagnetic radiation the light that
impinges on our retina giving a
two-dimensional image that's all
scrambled and interpreting that has a
three world of three-dimensional objects
moving around in three-dimensional space
that's a very difficult in fact
impossible mathematical problem but we
have many sophisticated tricks and rules
of thumb plus a systematic although
unconscious knowledge of projective
geometry so that we can recognize that
emit the same thing seen from different
positions is this represents the same
object these were when they were made
conscious as geometric theorems and
discoveries astonishing achievements
that when Brunelleschi discovered the
science of perspective in 1420 helped
kicked off kick off the glorious episode
of the Italian Renaissance and has been
a foundation of art ever since
[Music]